welcome to this video playing our car
from Israel fmr com let's check them no
name yes let's let's play you for though
I don't know it ok doesn't it's no
problem here is playing a pretty
harmless line it's very unassuming just
giving white center let's see so here d5
looks very normal
now I guess so the question is now
Knight takes Knight cheeks or politics
I'm game taking with the night i'm not
sure about this
this is a move I didn't even consider
because it looks so so wrong really if
you can take them okay so rookie one
he's playing Bishop f5 how to believe
that this should work really hard to
believe okay let's let's start that I
won't won't take our stem can take 95
Bishop g6 Knight e5 is this the
refutation probably not i can take there
and play night I can play Bishop g5
Bishop d3 he will take them Queen d3s
awesome queen bee three
quindi three I don't know maybe he goes
be five then that looks totally sick I
thought I can take and play Bishop t5 so
maybe it's this then I don't know takes
Queen g5 also looked strong I mean if
this is playable night x before I would
be really shocked I mean so my idea is
just to play rookie form quite quite
primitive as usual I don't see what he
does if he moves in the nighttime
checking is seven with check
I see no move b5 some crazy move like
that i takee 755 that that's a totally
deadly situation so here he I can take
now here right and don't see an issue
there ok what is he doing here Queen g4
maybe not sure if if there is a threat
with the bishop I mean maybe I should
just develop him and let's develop if he
moves the bishop I just I just move the
Queen whatever Queen f5 actually might
be a good square looking at their seven
square
Queen f5 yeah
threatening 95 let's that would be
absolute curtains so what is he doing
now g6 looks completely wrong Knight f6
King edge HR not sure if I can complete
review that King age eight what then
maybe maybe just six I mean and actually
five is a huge threat and h6 okay you
can play age 60 mm but then I then I'm
actually taking therefore Knight f6
that's also pretty pretty bad
hmm i will remove nothing's there's some
kind of dicks disconnection going on I'm
okay and he is ok as well or she for
that matter you know you don't know um
hmm I don't know I would probably play
g60 I'd hope for the best so 95 is not
winning why not why is this not winning
okay show me
okay so it's just giving giving the
exchange them stick here for 96 check
hip scrap that as well black resins just
being greedy yeah I cannot absolutely
not believe that you can I mean I think
this position is good for white anyway
but Knight takes e4 cannot be played I
mean okay so queen e 2 is actually even
stronger then review one but that also
wins okay my move and and continuation
just win so okay this is this a stronger
according to the engine with this idea
don't get it yet and then 95 okay hmm
for takes takes and you have no move
here and like this is going to be
punished check in this regard this way
that's it just absolutely not playable
because of those hanging pieces yeah so
what I did is is also winning plus two
ya know okay I think we should be three
assists since decent and this is
probably winning the relatively I
thought g6 maybe this this and now I
didn't see yeah okay the computer
actually does agree I didn't see
anything better than that intending
Queen edge form and this should window
because the rook is attacked and I don't
know where it is going I'm also
threatening this move their widest was
completely winning yeah you simply
cannot take only for that so it looks
very strange with this piece kind of
under attack and end the e-file pile up
here so the very very it would be very
surprising if this is playable okay well
thanks for watching